[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video were going to be discussing
the chosen one Harry James Potter James
is also Harry's middle name in case you
didn't know
Harry's of course a pivotal driving
force in the Harry Potter franchise and
he's a very dynamic character that
evolves so much over the course of the
books and films however one thing that I
feel was truly overinflated in both
books and films was Harry's level of
power sure Harry beat Voldemort and sure
Harry proved that he was competent in
many different situations able to use a
plethora of applicable spells however if
you really dive deep into the franchise
it quickly becomes evident that most of
Harrod little victories the result of
unique circumstances extraneous magic
assistance from friends or just being
able to quickly think on his feet but
does that make him an innately powerful
wizard like the great Albus Dumbledore
or the powerful Lord Voldemort what does
that make him a a smart wizard with dare
I say it slightly above-average talent
if we were whined back to the day at
Godric's Hollow where Voldemort came to
murder Harry and his parents we can
recognize this as a very important part
in the story's history not only did it
mean the death of the widely loved Lily
and James Potter not only did it mean
the defeat of the Dark Lord it also
meant the survival of Harry Potter this
reputation having survived an attack but
the Dark Lord Himself preceded Harry and
when he finally entered the Wizarding
World
he almost already had this reputation
that he was powerful he didn't know the
world of magic at all but here he was
strolling down Diagon Alley with
everyone thinking that he had somehow
single-handedly stopped the Dark Lord of
course we know that in reality it was
the result of Lily's sacrificial
protection baby Harry didn't produce
some sort of complicated counter charm
it was his mother and yet he survived
but he didn't do anything because of all
of this
Harry's level of power is overinflated
right from the very beginning in an
interview regarding Neville Longbottom
JK Rowling reveals that had he been the
chosen one he also would have been able
to achieve what Harry had achieved he'll
quickly see that it wasn't magical power
that drove his achievements it was just
his strength of
I love Neville I love Neville so much
always love Neville and I always had big
plans for Neville you know and he was
really the boy it could have been
because as you know as I made clear he
was born hours before Harry he was born
on the 30th of July
Voldemort singled him out as the other
possibility but the great thing about
Neville story for me the overarching
story about Neville is that he proves
himself to be a boy who could have done
it too yeah Harry had the scar and
arguably Harry had an edge more talent
because Harry he has an extraordinary
instinct for the right thing to do he's
just got the right instinct and that's
what would make him in due course a
phenomenal aura but Neville was I think
amazing in the final battle and proved
himself a hundred times over worthy of
being a Gryffindor despite the very
difficult childhood he had in the hands
of his very pushy grandmother and I know
she loves him and he loves her but she's
not an easy person to be raised by so
yeah so that for me was the big thing
about Neville he's not on the surface I
suppose he's not as cool when it comes
right down to it although Harry of
course made himself cool he was a
scoring little kid in glasses he comes
through and it becomes the guy everyone
wants to know so as you can see in JK
Rowling's own words Harry had an edge
more talent than Neville and yet never
went on to achieve some great things but
was in no way one of the most talented
visits ever and Harry's just a hair
ahead of him
while Harry was not a bad student he
also wasn't exceptional he wasn't
Hermione his grades were above average
across the board but there were few
areas that he did not particularly excel
in Harry's eventual success in potions
where it was previously a weak subject
for him could almost be entirely
attributed to his use of Snape sold
potions book the book of the half-blood
Prince was why Harry was good at potions
not because Harry was good at potions in
the Chamber of Secrets Harry defeats the
fabled southern basilisk and sure it was
a great victory of her monstrous
creature with a killer instinct but
again does that make him a powerful
wizard his victory was largely a result
for my his research and honestly a lot
of dumb luck Harry didn't produce some
massive fiend fire that incinerated the
basilisk first folks showed up and
called out the basilisks eyes there's
the first example of the extraneous
assistance that I had mentioned earlier
next the
laughing hat provides Harry with the
Sword of Gryffindor a sword presented to
only a true worthy Gryffindor
now that the basilisk can't see how he's
able to stab the basilisk through the
roof of the mouth effectively defeating
it but what would have happened if folks
didn't show up if Harry wasn't a worthy
Gryffindor he wouldn't have been quite
so lucky
additionally Harry didn't actually use
any magic he just use a sword so you
could even argue that he could have even
defeated the basilisk as a squib in this
circumstance
Harry's next notable victories surround
the Triwizard Tournament as we know the
Goblet of Fire aligns the events of the
tournament tournament that Harry was
competing in as a representative for
Hogwarts what Harry did not know however
was a while participating in the
tournament he's being given a win his
advantage one of all des morts followers
Barty Crouch jr. did everything in his
power to ensure that Harry would end up
a winner in the hedge maze and turn the
Triwizard Cup into a portkey this port
key would lead to little Angleton the
same place that Voldemort was undergoing
his transformation into his proper form
so once again while he was successful in
atonement he once again had outside help
when Harry eventually arrives at little
Angleton he's met with Voldemort and
Wormtail who are brewing a regeneration
potion the potion as a whole required
three ingredients when a father flash of
a servant and butter foe to create the
potion Wormtail in Bosch Crouch jr.
helped Voldemort source these
ingredients and with it they were able
to create the potion successfully by
using worm tails flesh Voldemort's
father's bone and harry's blood after
assuming his new all-powerful form
Voldemort summons an array of death
eaters and begins to address Harry
Voldemort in typical Voldemort fashion
begins his monologue and essentially
proclaims that Harry's survival 13 years
prior was purely a fluke and he's really
not wrong here
he knows that Harry isn't innately
powerful enough to defeat him on his own
and challenges Harry to achoo he's so
unafraid that he even taunts him the
next thing you know Voldemort has cast
his signature Avada Kedavra
no surprises there and Harry has hit
back with expelliarmus a jet of green
light issued from Voldemort wand just as
a jet of red light blasted from Harry's
they met in midair and suddenly Harry's
one was vibrating as though an electric
charge were surging through it
his hand seized up around it he couldn't
have released it if he'd wanted to in a
narrow beam of light connected the two
ones neither red nor green but bright
deep gold at this point in time a Harry
can't let go of his wand and neither can
Voldemort they are both raised into the
air and moved to a clear piece of ground
away from the graves and the beam of
light connecting their ones turns into a
golden domed web what can occur when two
brother ones go into contact with each
other is a phenomenon called two priori
Incantatem it is also known as a reverse
spell effect this is exactly what
happened to Harry and Voldemort in the
Goblet of Fire if two wizards are
fighting each other and this occurs they
are effectively locked into a battle of
wills the spells become intertwined when
they meet a connection is hard to break
so did Harry's expel yamas best the
powerful Avada Kedavra because harry was
a more powerful wizard
definitely not he won out of strength of
character and sure what he did was
impressive but once again I'm looking at
midnight magical power and that was not
the reason that Harry won in the
graveyard
Harry's next big victory is over
Voldemort during the Battle of Hogwarts
the famous end of Lord Voldemort this
was a big win for Harry and it gave him
an even bigger reputation as being
magically talented and powerful once
again Harry's victory was so
circumstantial when Harry's expelliarmus
beats Voldemort Avada Kedavra once again
they're locked into yet another power
struggle at the dead center of the
circle they'd been treading mark the
point where the spells collided Harry
saw Voldemort green jet meet his own
spell they saw the elder one fly high
dark against the sunrise spinning across
the enchanted ceiling like the head of
Nagini spinning through the air towards
the master it would not kill who had
come to take full possession of it at
last
Harry with the unerring skill of the
seeker caught the one in his free hand
as Voldemort fell backwards arms blade
the slip pupils of the Scarlet eyes
rolling upwards Tom Riddle hit the floor
with a mundane finality
his body feeble and shrunken the white
hands empty the snake like a face vacant
and unknowing Voldemort was dead killed
by his own rebounding curse and Harry
stood with two ones in his hand
staring down at his enemies shell so in
essence Harry won because he was the
rightful owner
the Elder Wand it wasn't really anything
else it also didn't help Baltimore's
case that he had used Harry's blood in
his regeneration potion because
Voldemort used Harry's blood to rebuild
himself a part of Harry and Lily lived
inside him
Voldemort believed that this would allow
him to successfully attack Harry while
simultaneously being shielded by Lily
sacrificial protection however this sort
of backfired
as in doing so he actually
unintentionally rendered Harry the only
person capable of killing him so you
might be wondering where did Harry's
real strengths lie what did he do in the
franchise that really made him stand out
as it perhaps powerful wizard the first
really impressive thing about Harry was
his ability to fly a broom almost
immediately
Harriet was comfortable on the broom in
Madame ouches class and he's so talented
that he's almost immediately picked up
for the Quidditch team while flying
broom is quite physical there's also a
magical component but does find a broom
really make you powerful that's a bit
much next Harry could resist the effects
of the Imperius curse which was also
quite an impressive feat but it came
down largely to strength of character
which Harry had an abundance of not
necessarily magical power
Harry's true most notable accomplishment
was his ability to produce a corporeal
Patronus which is post Newt level magic
at a very young age with all of the
run-ins with Dementors that Harry had
his need for expecto patronum was
evident as it is the only known defense
against both Dementors and leather
faults not only is it massively useful
for Harry it is also quite a difficult
spell to cast Harry learns it at an
extremely young age and eventually
teaches the members of Dumbledore's Army
had to cast it as well learning it so
young is in my eyes his most impressive
magical feat and the only true area that
Harry shows us truly impressive innate
magical ability but of what I want to
mention is that the strengths of Harry
Potter lie in his strength of character
his perseverance his purity his
unfailing courage as well as the strong
relationships that he makes he wasn't a
magical genius like Dumbledore but he
was slightly gifted in the practical
application of magic
aside from that there was nothing
terribly remarkable about Harry
he was just an average boy thrust into
confusing and challenging circumstances
a truly relatable main character
anyway that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please be sure to like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]